I personally when I started this as a
math nerd wanted to pay off the highest
interest rate first which is
mathematically correct it's only
mathematically correct if you have the
same probability of
completion however when you pay off the
highest interest rate first or you start
monking around with paying off balances
that feel good you don't have the same
probability of completing the whole get
out a debt plan and when you enter
probability into the mathematics because
you messed with the behavior tool then
you you you you lower your completion
rate and all that Garb go to say if you
don't go get out of debt because you
screw with the plan then your plan was
dumb you know that's what it amounts to
so what what we've proven is is that
personal finance is 80% Behavior it's
only 20% head knowledge it's not a math
problem if we were doing math we
wouldn't have gotten in credit card dad